Welcome back to human emotion.
So these three familiar faces that you've
seen at the beginning of every lecture,
perhaps they're from different
backgrounds and if so,
would we expect them to actually show
or experience differences in emotion as
well?
So in this lecture,
what we're going to discuss today is to
what extent emotions are indeed shaped
and tune by culture and
different backgrounds.
So how is it possible that we could
show differences in emotion based on our
cultural background?
In other words,
our emotions actually culturally shaped.
This is the question we want to grapple
with today. Is it that, you know,
in some ways we may have overestimated
how hardwired or sort of how
biologically, you know, uh,
strengthen these emotions are,
have we underestimated the role that
our actual life experience and cultural
contexts can play in shaping who
we are as an emotional being?
So today what I want to do is sort of
delve inside with you to get a sense of
what is culture and in what ways to date.
We know that culture does indeed plays a
role in influencing our emotional life.
So we're going to do this by going
through the following roadmap.
First introduced to some terminology
relevant to the field of culture and
emotion. Next we'll go through some
key examples that demonstrate, uh,
the ways in which culture indeed
does influence our emotional lives.
We'll conclude with this
question of nature or nurture.
We had started with talking about sort
of evolutionary and more biological
origins of emotion.
And today we're going to be talking about
evidence suggesting that maybe context,
cultural context,
social influences may also influence the
way we experience and express emotions.
So our emotions,
more a product of our nature,
inherent nature or more a product
of nurture or environment.
And we'll conclude with takeaway questions
and an expert interview today with Dr
Jeannie Psi. So let's start
with some basic terminology.
I think what we really need to start
with first is the question of exactly,
well what is culture here?
When we think about what is culture,
there's a definition that is
common across different fields,
defining culture as human phenomena
that cannot be easily explained by or
attributable to genetics or biology.
So some examples of what culture is or
sort of what is the scope of over which
culture, uh, presides
include some examples here.
So culture includes systems of meaning
to interpret the world as well as
concepts that are transmitted
through social participation.
So examples include language,
um, sort of social customs.
These are sort of the, you know,
fabric of what makes up culture.
So when we think about exactly
how culture shapes emotion,
there are two different perspectives that
scientists have when they think about
this question.
One of them on the left is what
we talked about previously.
You might remember this evolutionary
perspective to emotion that suggested that
emotions are biologically rooted
part of our evolutionary history.
They serve specific functions and their
universal across cultures and other
words,
meaning there should be no cross cultural
variation that emotions are really
part of our biological
and evolutionary history.
So that's a first perspective we covered.
The second we're going to talk more in
detail about today that we touched on
previously is this idea of social
constructivism also called cultural
relativism. Here, it takes
a much stronger stance,
really suggesting that culture plays a
tremendous role in shaping and creating
our emotions.
So again,
emotions here as you can see on the right
and purple are constructed by cultural
values,
institution and language biology,
both the brain and are sort of autonomic
nervous system. Our thoughts to play,
little to no role in emotions whatsoever.
And in fact emotions are
these open systems and they
can be constructed in many
different ways. So this takes
a really strong stance. In
fact saying that culture,
you know,
not only influences our emotions but
can even create certain emotions for us.
So what do we know then about the
role of culture in shaping emotion?
Sort of what is the evidence to date?
So this is going to take us to our second
stop here on the roadmap where we're
going to talk about what do we know
about cultural influences on emotion?
Exactly how can it shape our emotion?
How can it create emotions?
How does it modify the kinds of
triggers that would elicit emotions and
different people? So let's turn
here now to the evidence to date.
Looking at cultural influences on emotion.
So I'll start with the first example to
answer this question of how exactly does
culture shape emotions.
So one example here is that
culture suggest what are
the appropriate solicitors
also refer to the antecedent
conditions for an emotion.
So what I mean by this is the following.
So although most of us,
for example, can think of snakes that
elicit fear and everyone across cultures,
we also see specific types of illicit hers
that are unique to different cultures.
So for example,
you can see here that work that's
looked at frequent antecedents of uh,
emotion across different
cultures. Find thing, finds
things like in us culture. Um,
we see that relationships
are highly valued.
And so things that elicit joy
within the US include relationships,
bonds with our partners, bonds
with families, with children.
So that seems to be a really common
elicit or for what would elicit joy or
happiness. Now, what if we look at
different cultural context? Do they have,
you know, the same types of antecedents,
oral listeners of joy and happiness?
Like what most frequently elicit these
kinds of emotions in different cultural
contexts? Interestingly, we know
that Israel values achievement.
So if you ask people the commonly report
what makes them feel happiness or joy,
they're more likely to give you examples
of times in which they accomplished
something of value or achieved or one
something that signaled their own sense of
accomplishment.
By contrast,
if we look at the up to Eskimos,
they report something quite different.
Um, they report, um, frequent
antecedents are elixirs of joy,
which include chasing lemmings as
you can see here on the bottom.
So what we're seeing here is that the
frequency of the kinds of antecedents or
elixirs of joy can have a lot of
cultural influence varying widely from,
you know, the u s to Israeli
cultures to these, um,
[inaudible] Indian or sorry,
at Ku, Eskimo cultures as well.
A second example here of how culture,
shapes and motion.
So we also know that culture is
shaped the appraisals of emotion.
So here you can ask a couple
of really important questions.
So do the same appraisals lead to
the same emotions across cultures?
In other words,
does threat always lead to fear?
And do people appraise
situations similarly, uh,
across cultures? So, in other words,
does threat mean the same thing to all
people even if they come from different
cultural backgrounds? So, um,
I'm just briefly refreshing
our memory here of a,
in our theories of emotion timeline from
the very beginning of the course where
we talked about these
cognitive theories of emotion.
And the reason that I'm bringing this
up again is this is really this sort of
foundation upon which we
know that appraisals, uh,
play a really important role
in giving rise to emotions.
So it's the appraisals of a situation
that give them meaning in the first place
that then would lead to the sort of,
you know,
heart rate acceleration and
experience of emotion fear.
Here's you can see in this example.
So this is just to underscore that
the idea of appraisals giving rise to
emotions has been ingrained in our
conceptions of emotion since Lazarus first
brought up his cognitive
theory of emotion.
But now it's until recently that we're
starting to look at whether or not these
appraisals can actually
differ across culturally.
So one example,
as you can see here is an
example using a group of fish.
Okay. So you see this group of fish.
And if you were asked the question,
what do you think the fish right here
on the front, what is he feeling?
So Americans who were asked this question
of what does the fish in the front
feel are more likely to say that the
fish is angry and that he's leaving the
rest of the fish because he
wants to get away from the group.
And people think that this
might be because in the u
s we really focus on these
individualistic values, ways in which
we are different from the group.
And so in this way, what you're
seeing is this fish in the front,
he must be different in
the group in some way.
And the emotion often attributed to
explain that more individualistic focuses.
Well the fish just feeling angry.
Okay.
If you were to ask people however from
a more Chinese backgrounds and ask them,
okay, well what do you think the
fish in the front is feeling?
They're more likely to say that the
fish and the front is feeling sad. Um,
and in fact, he may feel lonely and
rejected from the rest of the group.
And this is thought to be explained by
a different set of cultural values that
instead of focusing on more
individualistic values like
Americans, um, there's,
uh,
increasing emphasis instead
on collectivistic values
of wanting to be part of a
group, um, having your identity as
part of a bigger collective whole.
And so when you're
separated from the group,
that's actually something that feels
quite negative or aversive and you're
feeling sad as opposed to feeling angry
because you really want to get away and
you want to be different.
You want to lead the group and not be
sort of stuck and being part of that pack.
So this is some interesting
work suggesting that the
way that cultures appraise
different situations,
um,
is really quite different depending
on their own set of cultural values.
Here's an example of individualistic
versus collectivistic culture or values
that influence the motions that we
attribute to different scenarios.
So another way in which we can illustrate
this principle is through an example
that I, that I've really enjoyed here. Um,
that was given to me by a colleague
of Mine, David Pizarro at Cornell.
So imagine that you go to a friend's
house and you're told to help yourself to
the refrigerator.
How might you view this?
So research has found that Americans
view this situation in the following way.
So they view this situation as something
where they would feel pleasant.
Wow, I feel at home. You know, I can just
help myself to whatever's in the fridge.
They also report feelings of fairness,
um,
that they really feel that this act
is an act of courtesy and generosity
and also feeling, um, report, uh,
feelings of happiness because wow,
now they have the opportunity to really
just eat whatever they want in that
fridge. However, you see a
really different set of emotions,
uh, in response to the situation when
you look at a different cultural context.
So here, um, we know that Americans are,
would report feeling
happy in this context,
but in another culture such as Japan,
this situation is actually
appraised very differently.
So instead of seeing
feelings of pleasantness,
fairness and happiness arrives from the
situation, you see more frequent reports.
A feeling unpleasant,
um,
which is thought to be because the
host is refusing to take care of you.
They're sort of leaving you on your
own to figure out what to do with the
contents of food in their refrigerator.
You may feel that this is unfair.
So do you deserve this kind of rudeness
where someone just leaves you to help
yourself to find what you
need in the refrigerator?
And this may actually lead instead of
feelings to happiness, feelings of anger,
you just can't believe that they would
just sort of not say anything or guide
you or be a good house and just leave
you to sort of sort out for yourself what
is that you're supposed to eat.
So what's interesting about this example
is simply from looking at a fridge and
someone telling you to help yourself,
is that it can give rise to a completely
different cascade of emotions here in
this example,
depending on if you're from an American
background or Japanese background.
So what I think is really interesting
here is that we see appraisals, um,
not only differences in the kinds
of appraisals people may have,
but in the emotions that can follow
from these different appraisals.
So in how the situations themselves are
appraised differently and how this leads
on the one hand to feelings of
happiness in one cultural context.
And in another cultural context like we
talked about to feelings of anger, um,
and appraising the person was very rude.
And this is just from a
simple fridge example.
So what's a third way that we know
that culture can shape emotion?
Well,
here,
and I find some of this to be the most
interesting research is that culture
actually shapes the way that we express
our emotions through what's called
display rules.
So cultural display rules are defined
as when and how one is appropriately
allowed to express certain emotions.
They're sort of the rules that govern
how we sort of transmit emotions in our
face or in our nonverbal behavior.
So
a display rule to define it in more
detail are the cultural rules that dictate
how emotions should be expressed and
when and where their expression is
appropriate.
And there was one study that was done
here by freezing that really tried to
tease apart different display
rules according to different
cultural and societal
context.
So often a society's display rules
require people to give evidence of certain
emotions that they may not actually feel
or to disguise their true feelings in
context where they should
or ought not to show them.
So this is an example that was done
in a study by freezing in 1972.
Um, we had two of people, again,
they were American participants
or Japanese participants. Um,
in this study they were asked to view
a movie depicting a surgical procedure.
And as you can see here,
they viewed it either with an
experimenter in the room or alone.
And what we see here is that
the Japanese participants,
when they were with the experiment
or watching this really gruesome,
really awful surgical movie,
showed little emotional expressively.
They were in fact what was
thought of as stone faced.
So they suppressed a lot of their emotions
when they were around. Another person.
By contrast, when they were alone,
they actually showed, you know, the,
the typical kind of expressive
displays of emotion, right?
So they showed disgust and things of that.
Like by contrast, when we looked
at the American participants,
they displayed an emotional reaction when,
when,
when they're with the experimenter
and they displayed a similar emotional
reaction when they were alone watching
the surgical video. And in fact,
if you look just at the column
to the right here alone,
the Japanese and American participants
did not differ in their emotional
expressive, the, when they were alone,
they only differed when they were in the
context of the experiment or suggesting
that some of the display rules in Japanese
cultures may be to sort of suppress
or inhibit certain kinds of negative
emotional expressions when you're in the
context of another person.
Whereas the American participants did
not have those same types of cultural
display rules that they
were feeling, uh, you know,
appropriate to display whatever
emotional reactions they were feeling in
response to watching this video.
So it's interesting here is that you
see that certain display rules really
suggest that in certain social contexts
that may not be appropriate to express
emotions.
And another context it is.
So this graph is interesting too.
Um,
and that it's giving other types of
examples that display rules as to how
frequently one should be expressing
emotions dramatically differs across the
world. So what you see here is a
lot of different countries here, um,
depicted by these
different purple circles.
And on the left side you hear how much
they endorse expressing emotions overall.
And the point I want you to take away
from this graph is that there's a lot of
variability and the types of expressivity
that people endorse and importantly
that we just talked about consistent with
the studies we've found is on the top
right, you see the u s
very, very high, right?
So some of the display rules in the u
s are that it's very appropriate and
highly common to express emotions
frequently and intensely. In fact,
we're way here up at the top. And you
can contrast this with other countries.
Some of them that we've talked about,
Japanese cultures are much less lower on
their overall expressively endorsement.
I'm down here,
you have Hong Kong.
And so you really see an interesting
spread in terms of the overall degree to
which different cultures display emotions
at different intensities and different
frequencies.
So example for how else can
culture shape emotion? Well,
we see here that culture can also give
shape to the value that we place on
experiencing emotions or the way in
which we give it special premium or
importance in our life.
So this is an example that I always find
really interesting and it is based on
the work of Jeannie side at Stanford
University who will speak with and our
expert in emotion interview
series. Uh, later today.
She really put forth this concept of
an effect of valuation or how much,
um,
personal value we place on experiencing
different kinds of emotions,
sort of what our, our, our emotional
ideals or emotional standards.
So we'll talk a bit more about her
work just now an aspect of valuation.
So some of you may have seen the movie
or read the book where the wild things
are. And if, so,
you may remember a character who was
named Carol and he was full of these mini
kind of wild and unleashed emotions.
So on the left you can see
this picture of Carol. Um,
and what is a representation of what
Jeannie Syrah refers to as actual aspect.
So this is how Carol actually feels.
Um,
and so these are just the moment emotions
in the moment that he feels a on a day
to day basis.
Now what's really important is to contrast
this on the right with what's thought
of as his ideal aspect.
So this is the idea of how
he would actually like to
feel if he had his choice,
what would be his ideal emotional self.
And what's really interesting as well,
actual effect on the left is thought to
be shaped more by biological forces like
temperament or genetics ideal.
An effect on the right is instead
thought to be shaped more by culture.
So it includes like meaning thoughts,
beliefs,
values and practices that are promoted
within a particular cultural context that
shape the kinds of emotions one ought
to feel or one should try to strive to
feel.
And this,
if you think about just how exactly
culture exerts an influence on the sort of
ideal aspect or an effect valuation,
the emotions you value and want to feel,
you can think of it this way.
So there's a grid here which has been
referred to as the effect of circumplex.
And what you can see here is um,
on one dimension we have negative
to positive sort of left to right.
So this is a valence dimension.
And by contrast you can see on the top
to bottom as a more sort of arousal or
activation dimension.
Okay.
So this depicts a landscape of emotions
that we talked about earlier in the
course when we were thinking about two
different perspectives to conceptualizing
emotion and looking at sort of approaches.
So it's something we've talked about here.
How might we suspect culture would
place a premium or on different kinds of
emotions? So when we think of
more Western cultures like the US,
what kind of emotions do we think
that people ideally want to feel?
What is their ideal aspect?
So this is work done by Jeannie side
that's found that western culture is
commonly report.
When you ask them what is the kind of
emotion or affect you want to feel,
they say they want to feel these
high arousal, positive emotions,
what she calls hap emotions.
So these include things like feeling
enthusiastic, elated and excited.
This is where most of
us want to go towards.
Now this is in stark contrast with
more eastern cultures by contrast,
who report wanting to strive towards
what's called these low arousal positive
emotions or lap emotions so to speak.
So they're gravitating more
towards an ideal aspect of state,
of feeling relaxed,
calm and peaceful.
So what's really interesting here is that
we have different cultural values that
are sort of pushing us
in different directions,
both towards feeling more positive
emotion. But on the one hand,
one is very high and active and excited.
Kind of this go getter attitude in a
western culture and the other and eastern
cultures is really more
focused on obtaining serenity,
equanimity and calmness.
And so this is some of the work
that Jeannie size really pioneered.
And we'll speak with her more later
today and the expert in motion, uh,
interview series.
So here,
here's a fifth example of just how many
ways we can see that culture is shaping
emotion.
So we see that culture also influences
which emotions are emphasized or talked
about within a given, uh, cultural
groups. So in other words,
which emotions are highly regarded,
sort of what are the kinds of emotions
that seem to capture our attention and
that are represented in our
everyday language here the
distinction is often made
between two things,
hyper cognizant emotions
and Hypo Cognizin emotions.
So as you can see here,
hyper cognizant emotions are those that
are highly emphasized in a culture.
They become objects of discussion and
they have this kind of elaborate cognitive
structure usually seen within
these rich vocabularies.
We have a lot of words that sort of orbit
around these emotions that we really
highly emphasize in.
And really seem to be almost sort of
obsessed with in a way as a culture.
By contrast,
these hypo cognized emotions are
relatively underemphasized within a given
society and they have a really
limited cognitive structure.
So we see very few words that
represent these emotions.
So let me walk you through some examples
of what are culturally distinct,
hyper and Hypo cognitivist. So, um,
hyper cognates, an emotion
within Western cultures is love.
We talk a lot about love,
um,
not only our own everyday love, but we
have these romanticized kind of, you know,
novels with these picture best images
that are sort of burned in our minds and a
lot of really trashy celebrity pop culture
is also about love. Who's together,
who's breaking up, who cheated on who. Um,
so we just talk a lot about this and we
also have these notions of love at first
sight. You know, this kind of love
that turns your world upside down. Um,
and we also talk a lot
about other kinds of love.
This kind of slow growing
love that takes time, uh,
is deep and strong and can
happen with many people.
We really seem to be obsessed
with love in western cultures.
Um, by contrast, um,
when we think of what our
hypo cognized emotions are,
the to Haitians here, interestingly,
the hypo and emotion for them,
uh, is sadness. They have no
linguistic concept of sadness.
They tend to think of sadness
more as a physical condition,
then an emotional state. So you don't
see it represented in a lot of, you know,
images in their culture.
You don't see it highly talked about,
you don't see these kind of elaborate
or ritualistic stories about sadness the
way that Westerners do about love.
So we've talked about hyper and Hypo
cognized emotions and who I want to
conclude with the sixth example or way
in which culture may shape emotion.
So we talked a little bit about the kinds
of emotions that are frequently spoken
about love and sadness.
Um,
but culture not only influences which
kinds of emotions get attention,
but it also shapes our
very language of emotion.
So let me explain what I mean
here. So we know, for example,
that there's culture specific
emotion words. So, for example,
in Japan they have this particular word,
a my,
that refers to this indulgent feeling of
dependency sort of akin to what a child
might feel for its mother.
And these are feelings of dependency that
are highly valued within this cultural
contexts. Um, that's a very sort of
interdependent and collectivistic.
So this is a word that you see in Japanese
cultures that we just don't have in
westernized cultures that are not as
interested in or sort of whose values
aren't sort of orbiting around depending
on and being intertwined with others.
Instead, we have this more autonomous
or individualistic culture.
So these are specific emotion words that
are highly emphasizing and created by
the cultural contexts. Um, another
example is shot in Freud, uh,
from Germany.
Some of you may be familiar with this
and at the idea of sort of experiencing
pleasure at another person's expense.
We don't have a word for this
exactly in our own culture. Um,
this is something that's really
generated by, uh, you know,
German culture specifically. Though we
may be familiar with it and understand it,
we don't have a specific
word for it per se.
And then there's this other interesting
emotion and the Czech Republic, um,
which is emotion,
the tossed.
And this is an emotion that is defined
as torment caused by the sudden insight
into one's own miserable self.
So I don't know if you can
think of a word like this, uh,
in your own sort of English vocabulary.
But this is thought to be a unique
type of emotional experience, again,
influenced by one particular culture.
So the overarching point here is that
culture not only shapes the kinds of
emotions we value the kinds of emotions
we place a high premium on the kinds of
appraisals or meanings we
give emotional situations.
But it can even influence the very
nature of the language and the words that
we're using to express emotions such
that different cultures in fact have
different emotional words.
And you may argue though
it's controversial for some,
but they may actually have very different
emotional lives altogether given that
they think about emotions,
they talk about emotions differently,
and they even have distinct types of
emotional words that some cultures don't
have.
So I want to talk a little now about
this idea of culture specific absences.
So James Russell did this very interesting
study where he reviewed ethnography
is describing everyday
lives and other cultures.
And here he found that some cultures
simply have no words for certain emotions.
Um,
so he talked about this in
terms of culture specific
absences of certain emotion
words. So you can see a few examples
here that I've highlighted. For example,
it seems that there may be no sort of
words for disgust in Polish cultures.
We talked a little bit about the Hypo
Cognos emotions of sadness into Haitian
cultures, but they also
don't have specific words for
feelings of guilt as well.
What's interesting that
I find here is that, uh,
in Tibetan culture is there's actually
no particular word that designates or
kind of picks out this
concept of even emotion.
So what this course that you're taking
is about that focuses on human emotion.
They don't even have a word to describe
that specifically or pick that out.
Um,
and finally you can see that a Indonesian
cultures don't really have words for
embarrassment. Something we'll
talk about later on in the course.
So not only are there certain specific
unique emotion words that, uh,
occur in certain cultures,
but there's also an absence
of other emotion words, um,
and different cultures.
So we really see a lot of variation in
the language of emotion and our ideas of
which emotions exist and occur and
that we talk about in our everyday
experiences.
So what's really important here though,
we've talked a lot about language
and how language can shape, um,
the kinds of emotions we talk
about on a frequent basis.
How language can shape which emotion
words we have in the first place,
and how language can also shape the
absence of certain emotion words in our
everyday dialect.
But what's really important here is
to make sure that you understand that
language is separate from the actual
subjective experience of emotion.
So we don't want to make the inference
that language is the same thing as
emotion experience.
Um,
so just to keep in mind here that
language is not equal to experience,
but what language does provide us some
insight and is the way that people
cognitively represent or sort of
transmit their understanding or ideas of
emotion experience.
But we need to be careful not to
assume then that certain cultures don't
experience, you know, embarrassment
for example, or sadness.
It's just simply something that's not
represented in their sort of current,
uh, you know, dialect or way
that they speak about emotion.
So that's just an important caveat that
you want to make sure to sort of keep in
the background as you think about some
of these findings that relate to the way
that culture shapes emotional language.
So now in our roadmap,
I want to just conclude with this
broad question of nature or nurture.
So we spend a lot of time in our earlier
lectures talking at length about just
how we are these evolutionary kind of or
originated species that were built with
hardwired emotions like fear,
disgust, anger, sadness.
You know,
that these are really built to sort of
deal with these recurrent evolutionary
situations.
You know,
seeing a snake or seeing a disgusting
substance that we need to have these
emotions built in us to help us survive
and help us reach our evolutionary goals.
At the same time,
we spent some time today to talking
about how it's not quite that simple that
we're not simply the product of our
more biological or evolutionary past,
that the particular culture we grow
up in shapes the way we interpret
situations.
It could just be a body of fish swimming,
do does the fish look angry or sad?
It could be the words we
use to represent emotion.
It also influences the kinds of emotions
we want to feel or those that we place
a high degree of value or premium on.
So then how do we answer
this question of emotion?
Is it something that's more a product
of nature or more product of nurture?
And here what I wanted to picture with
these circles is that bottom line,
no surprise to most of you. I don't think
we can pick either nature or nurture,
right? Emotions are multifaceted
and they have multiple causes.
These causes can include evolution,
biology, individual development,
situational factors,
one's own temperament or
personality as well as culture,
which we talked a bit about today.
And what we need to think about carefully
is how these different sort of, uh,
causes of emotion overlap and intersect
to sort of give rise to the unique
emotions that we all feel, that
sort of makeup who we are. Um,
and sort of tease apart the different
contributions that each of these puzzle
pieces I think of, uh, you know,
sort of fit and how they put together
to make up each individual person.
So it's neither a nature or nurture.
And now I want to conclude
with our takeaway questions.
So for this brief module
today on culture and emotion,
okay,
the first question that you should be
able to answer and to kind of take home
from what we've spoken about today
is what is culture and what are,
or were the two main
competing perspectives of the
role of culture on emotion
that we discussed today?
Yeah.
Second,
I'd like you to name and describe at
least five though we talked about actually
six different sources of
cultural variation on emotion.
So what are some of the examples and
empirical data that suggest that there is
an important role that culture plays
in shaping our emotional experience,
expression and language for emotion.
Okay.
And finally,
yeah,
what are hyper cognizant
and Hypo cognized emotions.
So you should be able to define what
each of these two are and you should be
able to give an illustrative examples,
uh,
to sort of tease apart what these two
different categories of emotions are.
And now I want to conclude with
our expert interview. And again,
this is part of our broader experts
and emotion interview series.
Okay.
For today we have the honor of
speaking with Dr Jeannie Psi, um,
about the question regarding to what
extent our emotions culturally shaped Dr
Sigh received her phd in
clinical psychology from
the University of California
Berkeley and did her clinical internship
and post doctoral fellowship in
minority mental health at the
University of California San Francisco.
She's currently an associate professor
of psychology at Stanford University and
director of the culture and emotion lab.
Dr [inaudible] research focuses on how
cultural ideas and practices shape our
feelings, identities, and even
mental health. She's highly regarded,
especially for her work that we
discussed today on asset valuation across
cultures.
She's received numerous awards,
including a young investor investigator
award from the National Alliance for
research on schizophrenia and depression,
an early career award for contributions
from the Asian American Psychological
Association and the Dean's Award for
distinguished teaching from Stanford
University.
So I now turn to a very special experts
and emotion interview with Doctor
Jeannie Sy.